You've already seen how convolutional
network uses shared parameters across
space to extract patterns over an image.
Now you're going to do the same thing
but over time instead of space.
This is the idea behind
recurrent neural networks.
Imagine that you have a sequence
of events, at each point in time
you want to make a decision about what's
happened so far in this sequence.
Imagine that you have a sequence
of events, at each point in time
you want to make a decision about
what's happened so far in the sequence.
If your sequence is
reasonably stationary,
you can use the same classifier
at each point in time.
That simplifies things a lot already.
But since this is a sequence, you also
want to take into account the past.
Everything that happened
before that point.
One natural thing to do here is to use
the state of the previous classifier
as a summary of what happened before,
recursively.
Now, you would need a very deep neural
network to remember far in the past.
Imagine that this sequence could
have hundreds, thousands of steps.
It would basically mean to have
a deep network with hundreds or
thousands of layers.
But instead,
we're going to use tying again and
have a single model responsible for
summarizing the past and
providing that information
to your classifier.
What you end up with is a network with a
relatively simple repeating pattern with
part of your classifier connecting to
the input at each time step and another
part called the recurrent connection
connecting you to the past at each step.